welcome back to cbs saturday morning we
begin this half hour with a snapshot of
the late general colin powell funeral
services are set for november 5th for
the four star general who served four
presidents while he will be known as the
nation's first african-american chairman
of the joint chiefs of staff and its
first black secretary of state his
one-on-one ability to connect with
people is coming to light one veteran
discovered this in the least likely of
places mike valerio of our washington
affiliate wusa tv reports
i was about two feet away from when i
said you're general cole and powell and
he said yes i am and i said well let's
get to changing this tire that's how the
banter began on the beltway between an
american luminary and retired army major
tony maggart powell noticed maggart's
leg partially amputated in afghanistan
right away and tony said were you
waiting around for a two-legged guy but
you got a one-legged guy he's willing to
help you right now so he changed the
secretary's tire their selfie went viral
on facebook but weeks later tony tells
us i was in the gym and i got a phone
call and he goes hey man
this is general colin powell and he
literally said that hey man this is
general colin powell's like oh hey sir
how are you he goes we got to do dinner
i'm like what are you talking about he
is yeah i want your family and and me
and my wife to have a dinner together
and this is the photo from that dinner
tony says the secretary was funny humble
and they grew close powell even confided
in tony his cancer diagnosis last year
he said
yeah i've got the cancer and i'm not
sure how much longer i'm going to make
it you know and you know you hear people
say that and you hope that that lasts a
lot longer and
he said i don't know if we'll make it
through the year
and you know i thought man that would be
terrible and then today is that terrible
day tony told us the news was a visceral
gut punch but he remembers the lesson
from that moment in animating energy for
each day you have to do good all the
time even even when you don't think
people are looking they might be right
and so it's just like be a good person
all the time in life
for cbs saturday morning mike valerio
washington
he made you feel that way when you met
him you just felt like he was a regular
guy having a conversation with you
he's sorely going to be missed that
dinner was great yeah fantastic